well who can forget the moment you
caught Gino on a sugar daddy website and
then when his ex sent topless photos of
you
to apparently you claim your job right
yeah you lost your job as an American
literature teacher
have you been able to forgive Gino for
sending those photos to his ex
my privacy
how can you do that
wow the reason why I
gave him a second chance is because when
he did it uh we were just dating but
that time when he sent those pictures we
were just dating online we have never
met in person yet and he never he never
thought that I will this person will
actually actually reach out to me and
there was gonna be a way in which I will
know what he did you know it was at the
very beginning of the relationship but
if Gino have done or if he could have
done
something like that ah
another point of the relationship when
we have already met in person when he
after he proposed to me that it was
something more serious I I don't think
that I will be able to forgive him but
that was by far the worst thing that he
did to me
um the last worst thing after that you
know uh I cannot recall him doing
something else about us well since we
lost your job you started an only fans
account right yeah how does Gino feel
about that
well I'm very open and transparent about
my you know job as a content creator in
only fans
um there might be a misconception about
only fans you know that I you know I am
guilty myself because in the past I I
look at this uh side juices
you know pornography like oh no that's
like you know explicit pornography but
actually you as a content creator you
decide how how far you want to go uh I'm
just there
I don't know modeling lingerie being
just sexy being you know provocative but
but Gino knows that I can there are
certain things that I cannot cross the
line for example no nudity you know we
agree as a couple there is not gonna be
no nudity maybe some transparent stuff
like it's in writing but you can see but
you can actually not see at all it's
just a place where I can be sexy and
that's it and and people can reach out
to me more directly than on social media
that there are thousands and thousands
of people this is like a more VIP area
you know sometimes people just want to
be listen and be friends and oh Jasmine
uh I just want to listen to your voice
you know this is something that they
have crazy fantasy you know like my
voice I don't really like my book and
I'm like good morning babe I just want
to wish you a happy wig and that's good
enough for for me to receive a hundred
five hundred dollars yes people are
insane oh girl have you ever thought
about acting people think you should be
on a Telemundo somewhere or somebody
stage girl your personality yeah that
and that is something that I was always
criticized about it was like you know
growing up as a girl because I come from
a very conservative kind of
old-fashioned and really very
traditional and I was always like you
know the extrovert and so loud and I was
always so like oh you have to hang out
and I was like well I like being myself
you know this is this is how I am
I'm very genuine sometimes
um I speak too much I'm very talkative
but if there is something I'm very proud
of it's like I have a good heart you
know I know that's not very humble to
say that but I do believe that pretty
much I'm a good person and I try my best
every day you know to improve so that's
that's what's really proud I think a lot
of people see that you know that you at
the end of the day you really you do
have a good heart
but I think it's a compliment in my
opinion oh thank you my computer yes
well I know when Gina first got to
Panama last season he wanted to put a
ring on your finger and he wanted to put
a baby in your stomach and you were like
you know we are not making a family
right now
we're not ready nope we are going
through too much to even think about a
baby right now but at this point is that
something you're still open to or
considering having a child with Gino
okay so hmm I have to be fair you know
uh yes you know the first time he came
to Panama he was in a hurry to get me
pregnant that was super crazy but
looking back and trying to show some
empathy to him you know he was already
in his 50s no kids and on my side I
already have two beautiful baby boys you
know and I and I have had that
experience I understand that and um I
don't want to take that away from Gino
but at the same time because I'm a
mother already myself and I know the big
responsibility that it is having kids
and I can tell because I look at my
mother girl I'm 36 and I'm still giving
headaches to my mom and whenever I need
her he's like Mommy you know she's there
for me so Lisa never ending job it's
either until you die literally
so because I know that and because I
have my kids I
as much as I want to give him that
opportunity made the dream come true
girl this is something that we still
need to discuss
and and and see first if we work as a
couple because I will be bearing for for
that to bring a human being into a such
a chaotic relationship like the one we
we have but if it happens you know
because you never know you know if
you're eating cake you know it might
happen sometimes it happen even when
you're taking precautions you never know
it happens but if I had you know the
power to decide when I would say I would
say that we still have a lot of things
to
before even thinking about kids so it's
not off the table you're just not
it's it has never been off the table of
course yes one part of me says yes but
this other part of me is saying like you
should stay away okay okay yeah when you
come to America let's speak it into
existence that's your goal you want this
K1 visa to get approved what does your
dream life look like here do you want to
live in Michigan is it Miami what's the
career look like
uh well it's it's hard to predict but
because I know myself you know uh and
I've been told that whether in Michigan
it's very low and I'm not even how
temperatures are very low I know that
that's gonna be something very hard for
me to adapt I don't see myself adopting
because even in you know I love Panama
you know I do believe that God is so
wise that he was like ah she is
definitely a soccer girl let's Place her
in front of me he threw me there you
know so I I don't know the United States
I never been there have never visited
the United States but I know it's a very
very big country and I'm quite sure that
if I don't like Michigan you know maybe
I can try a stay that is more similar to
my home country Panama I love her
actually good things about Miami maybe
Hawaii because I'm more like a you know
I like to wear bikini knees very little
fabric I work very harder and I'm not
gonna be covering my body layers and
layers of fabric just because of the
weather just starting by that oh I can't
wait to see what's in store for you and
Gina we're so happy you're back
oh thank you so much like you know
that's one of the I will say like the
biggest rewarding about being in in a
show like before the 90 day you know
it's it's that is it love that you
receive from people because they see you
every Sunday in their houses and they
feel like that like they know you and
they care about you and they defend you
and and they're so nice you know that's
that's the biggest reward and also the
opportunity to that the people can can
see a little bit of my country and
experience a little bit of my culture
and the most important part I I do
believe the philosophy of the show which
I love and that's why I love being part
of it is that love knows no borders he
doesn't know about a skin color he
doesn't know about different languages
different culture big when you love you
love you can profoundly deeply love a
person that is so different from you and
I can tell because you know it's so
different from me and there are so many
things just because of his culture let's
not talk about other things just because
of his culture and we are living even in
the same continent and I know that a lot
of viewers can feel identified and maybe
are going through the same and that's a
beautiful you know think about the show
and that's why I love him being part of
it and and and have the opportunity
for the people just to see my story play
out with the team
foreign
[Music]